[Music]
all right I'm going to go get my hair
done why why you going to spend the
money on all the hair stuff cuz I got to
get my hair done I can do it for you are
you sure yeah I do my mom my sister my
grandma my cousins my
friend everybody all right let's do
it okay Finish are you ready
yeah what the [__] did you do to my hair
it's dope right this is hot pink no it's
SL
brown what color is that it's
chut you're [__] color
[Music]
blind
anytime now come on come
[Music]
on tell me what you really like
baby my
God feel
coming feel
coming I feel it
[Music]
I feel it coming baby I feel it
coming I feel it coming
[Music]
baby Amanda me my friend friend
Sebastian he's from
Colombia I'm sorry you're from Colombia
yeah yeah yeah I'm from Columbia you're
amazing thank you really do you want to
come sure sure I'm sorry is this weird
oh no no no no no no no go have fun have
some fun
okay welcome thank
you it's meant to be I'd
say be your
[Music]
hero hey sa what do you call this like
AA a cola is what that computer
door all right up next we have
Amanda oh no I'm Amanda my name's Amanda
it's fine just go so you're a dancer
yeah I've been dancing since I was two
but I thought you were a comedic actress
I am but you know I I dance
also well there's only room for one this
is an audition for Dirty Dancing what
are you like five I'm actually 16 and
these Hips Don't
Lie all right girls whenever you're
ready me
I think we are going to go another
[Music]
way